I didn't hear but then Mike started
telling their about I'm a head butter
then I always said you know I was
hitting the thing come on
he banned us ahead butter I said my head
hurt too
I just went I was acting like it didn't
hurt come by momma told me we're gonna
happen if you do that he gonna do it
again and it worked that he hit me no
more
hey everybody welcome to a very special
episode of the box and hook off the
[ __ ] hook baby so cool I'm Evan
Britton
I'm Mike Tyson Mike we've got the champ
Evander Holyfield oh how at five-time
champ heavyweight champ the real deal
Holyfield brother how you doing man I'm
doing good what you doing in town man
well you down here for this event
yes awesome Evan asked them some
questions man I just want to first start
it off with I think it's awesome that
you guys have this relationship that you
have you know the battles that you've
been through it's like Clash of the
Titans with you guys now and talk about
a little bit about what your how you got
to this point of being friends after
some of the viciousness that you guys
went through and put each other through
I don't know how you tire you explaining
you know we known each other for long
since we're kids know you know and I
remember that's just stuff in the
beginning of the [ __ ] way
you know um I started doing the amateur
boxer in 1980 I won the National Junior
Olympics then in 81 I want him again I
guess in 1082 I won the National Junior
Nationals again and stuff and then I
went I guess to Ohio fair but but no I
fought some other Championships too and
I met these guys I'm a guy from all over
Matt Todd Hickman I met
Ricky won't matter at all these guys
Frank take I miss all these other
amazing fighters from different parts of
the country and they were always
successful fighter the best fighter we
always know where they enter the
tournament they were gonna win this and
that and we brought one and then one day
I came to the high state fair to
fighting that championship and then
everybody had said um look you won Mac
loss Frank take loss maybe it's like who
who beat them who [ __ ] be I don't
know some guy made Harley feel holy I
don't know it I don't know and they
never said his first name do you feel
holy who the [ __ ] is that you know so
that was the word gone another that's
how I first became aware of him well
yeah how old were you I was 16
Wow you first heard the name yeah how
old are you then what I was I was 20 oh
well I had made you to Pan American game
yet that's amazing
where did you grow up the vendor I grew
up in Atlanta gripping it led us and
when did you start boxing
start at eight years old and coming in
from the football field and oh wow and I
wanted to hit the speed back but the man
said you gotta be on the boxing team I
said well I want to be on the boxing
thing he said nope and it's for four
days he kept saying no then on that
Friday and I looked at him he looked at
me and shook his head and I ran up being
away and he let me in and told me I
don't want you to hit the speed back on
what you hit the heavy bag so I hit it
with all I can and I've knocked the skin
off my knuckles and he still laughing
when he stole laughs and I just kept
hitting him like this and he said you're
good thank you
he said do you know you could be like
Muhammad Ali as I'm only eight years old
he said you won't always be eight and
when he said that I knew next week our
gonna be I will gonna be nine so
believe so he asked me what did I think
I told him I had to ask my mama he said
what I said I gotta ask my mama so he
told me he said go ask that good mama
that you got and see what she say I said
mama she's what I said the white man at
the boys club said I could be like
Muhammad Ali and my mama said do you
know what they gonna do to you I said
well no she's they gonna hit you when
she said that I looked at her and I
started laughing I get three weapons a
day all my brothers and sister get a
chance to hit me I can't even hit them
back so my mom said well well you can't
hit them back like then she told me I
can get on the boxing team I go and in
the bathroom I looked at the mirror and
say Evander Holyfield a heavyweight
champ of the world it didn't sound good
but I said I kept saying it every time I
I go to the bathroom
I like this cuz I really want to make my
mama proud and so I go back and tell
miss Morgan my mama said I could be the
heavyweight champ of the world and he
looked at what I said my mama say I
could be the heavyweight champ of the
world
now I'm thinking this overnight agent
sees his son sit down let me tell you
this I don't have that much time because
he was 60 years old Miss Morgan and he
said I ain't got that much time he said
do you know what panaceas I said and I
said no he said hey she said cuz I got
to knows he's come and got that my son
he said this is what you want a fantasy
a fantasy when you want to do something
but Jane willing to work at it he said
oh so is this a fantasy or gold
he's called I ain't got that much time I
said well a goal he's okay then you
fight tomorrow the next day they putting
on the gloves and stuff and
he said see that kid right there I said
yes sir he said when the bell rang I
want you to run out that fast you can
and hit him in the nose and I said okay
so I looked at the kid and their coach
told him to run away hit me in the nose
and so my coach IRA didn't know what my
momma had told him he needed listen
father action don't quit now if you
don't make him do that then he's not
gonna box no more I said okay the bell
rang I run out there another kid run out
there so the white kid got close to me
and he closed his eyes I didn't close my
eyes I hit him red in the nose and he
strike crying he said Oh God and I
started crying and the referee stopped
the fight mr. Morgan get caught up in
the ropes trying to get in there and he
get through and he says do you know what
you've done
I said you told me to hit him in the
nose they said yeah you took your first
step and been a heavyweight champ of the
world like this hand Wow and they give
me this trophy so when I come home there
and I showed the trophy to my mama and
my mum put that smile on her face and
she put it on the shelf everybody came
in the house with said Miss Holyfield
who has the box and she would look at
she was smiled and said that little one
right there
they said he lived my mama said but he
can fight and that started off then all
of a sudden I went another trophy and
another trophy and I my mama like
trophies so I finally felt like I was a
part of the family because I could do
something real well talk about your
tournaments when's your first tournament
well you know of course you know and
from that point on I ran by for five
fights then then
I was helping I get I get I get 12 and
this Junior Olympic time then now on
fight kids all over the state of Georgia
and have fun no you see so many fighters
you never knew existed right right yeah
then you know you guys and everybody's
talking that's such as such that such
and such that's such a such a phone when
the Nationals twice I saw him when the
world Tony I saw him when the Olympic
and everybody names when anybody's
winning that the true there are badges
that they won that tournament and you're
[ __ ] involved [ __ ] real world it's
just a kid he's the best fighter in the
world anybody losing their mind yeah so
hey so here it is and my first loss I'm
like I fight this this kid now my my
brother had told me why boys couldn't
play and I and I thought he was telling
the truth because coach all the white
boys I played they said Oh God and they
like this but I'll dissent my coach mr.
Morgan who white told me said are you
afraid of this kid here and I looked at
him you know this kid was different from
the other white kids because he held on
velvet truck song and he have his
initials and his mom and dad went with
it
and this how was long huh all the other
kids had happy he had the short hair and
I already said Miss Moore asked me not I
said no cuz I looked at him because he
white now Wow
well godless to how you look and see
what I said that's what my thinking book
then all of a sudden the bell rung mr.
Barton say hit him in the nose why I hit
this boy reading a note and he hit me
back yeah understand feeling about so
that for the whole the whole town
me and him with toe to toe and the bell
rung that my first time they were
hitting the bell right now they used to
call me why not
one punch holder deal cuz I I just
stopped all of fighters I stop now Alda
said I go back to the colonist Marcus
said what's wrong I see he hit me back
he's a welcome to boxing and so I always
said go out the second round men this
guy go we go toe to toe for a minute and
a half like this miss mark said what's
wrong I say hit men and somebody say hit
him back in the stomach then I was sent
in the third round and the bell rung but
Sir Marcus said you got to go back out
and see who won and he said the winner
see Sir Colin and everything just went
quiet man I store crying and start I
start Holland and totally told mr.
bargain I didn't like him then why I
told her I quit I just said so I was
crying and they were trying to get me to
be quiet I'm like man I was so mad now
all the sudden I told mr. Morgan ain't
like him no more and all of this and I
quit boxing now go home and I tell my
mama and my mama said she didn't raise a
quitter so what that means she said you
going back and she said I don't care how
many time you're losing you going back
you don't quit now you go back and so
come Monday I went back and that's
Morgan asked me sue why are you doing
here that's because I said my mama said
I had to come back she looked at me did
I not tell you you had a good mama
so I met even more because I don't want
a boxing more it's a miss manga athlete
said why were you so crying and angry I
coach you told me I could be the
heavyweight champ of the world
he said well you can still be the
heavyweight champ in the world I said I
lost he said son you didn't lose
gave him the trophy and he said yeah cuz
he got the decision
he's and I said well did I mean I lost
he said no you did not lose I said then
why didn't get me the trophies because
you didn't get the decision I said what
I mean I lost he said no you lose when
you quit you when you in no boxer more
when you change your mind you ain't go
buy some more
that's me that you lost cause you quit
he said if you don't quit you eventually
gonna be the champion it's not time for
you to be the head we change the world
now today but but I thought that i'll
leave was undefeated I thought that's
the only way you could be he said it
ain't time yet if you don't change your
mind you gonna become the heavyweight
champ of the world so all of a sudden I
go and so it build my confidence up so
imma have to fight this white kid again
and I fight him and he beat me again and
I started crying start crying so I
realized that if I tell my mama she
gonna she don't make me go back so I
figured I make a sacrifice
I won't eat today I won't eat today and
my mom won't ask me no questions so I
come home and I take a shower just get
into bed and I hear my mom I asked my
brother where chubbier and she named
chubby yeah my nickname with Chuck yeah
so hard and so and my brother said he
don't feel good and I knew to have the
wrong answer
call who gonna tell a good mama that the
kid don't feel good and she's not gonna
go in there I hear walking boom boom
boom boom so I act like I was sleep and
she turned on like in she's and I know
she had to be holding a hand on her hips
Jesus looking and I wonder when she
gonna leave but I still have Lincoln and
she said but you opening my knock the
mothers are oh god I said ma'am she said
what's wrong with you I said I just
don't feel good mama she said you know
that thought the answer and she put her
hand on her hips and she said who won
that fight oh no when she said that I
realized that you know if you lied to my
mother it ain't over then whenever she
found out the truth for you getting a
whooping so I found that I read on lost
one shot so I ain't know since again
whoop again so I told the truth I lost
she said well okay then you know you got
to go back don't you
I said yes ma'am sir I realized I got a
dead being and went on in a beat does it
tell my mama don't found out that yeah
that daddy that I that's on reason why I
went gonna eat because they ain't wanted
to tell you the truth so I told the
truth a then all of a sudden then I
turned 13 and definitely everything
changed what happened because what
happen when I turned 13
now they got seasick all it now I was
now have a looking for cease of koloth
because whatever the sea Sakhalin way I
won't go away the same thing so you know
we used to fight at a hundred pound so I
brought a five-pound weight with me but
because I wasn't gonna fight see
Sakhalin cause he'd only way boy that
could beat me now all the other way
birth can be pronounced he's a college
kid but nobody else now I'm a dancer
round sisa College my brain this
five-pound weight so I had for my
friends who got on the boxing team
because they know whoever went
or win the tournament get to go out of
town and so this is gonna be our first
time staying in a motel so they told us
what we gonna do oh shoot man effort
everybody jumped in there so all my
friends hang they vote yet then they
don't know that white boys can fight so
they all know that so we we go we go to
the tournaments and they're going away
in and they see all white boys so now
I'll descend they say Holyfield we know
he gonna be white board I dipped it up
so I said man they said man these white
boys you know they can't fight so we all
win the first night the second night and
the third night so all of a sudden we
came to the final so we had to fight two
times in one day
I'm I used to do that twice a day Gary
round fights yeah yeah well so and so
Otto said Ilyich said come that evening
so they take us to they take us a Burger
King so we all had we all had whopper
french fries and shakes so the first guy
Lou the second guy who's the third guy
loses the fourth guy loose so I was the
last one they say offender we had cramps
that's where I ain't got no cramps they
said you're still gonna lose
I said no man I would lose but my mama
gonna get me so your mama what's the
excuse my mama said if I'd be the only
one show up then I had to do it man they
said well you gonna lose anyway I said
no I'm not so then you know that got a
cease to come I say he didn't show up
then they said then what is his name -
I'm right here
I see this kid named and I start crying
instantly I couldn't hold back the tears
and then they say see you crying already
so all of a sudden they followed me to
the club and table when they get to the
club in Tabor they see this white kid
they say you see Sakhalin he said yeah
they said you beat horn field he said
yeah you gonna beat him again and he
said yeah then they sir I told you gonna
lose and I just threw our crime right in
front of that kid
[Music]